[Music]
all season long we're highlighting home
towns all across the country because
there's no place like home
next step is seattle washington where
marley and anthony love call home
the loves love seattle and i have a
feeling we're about to also watch this
[Music]
hey drew it's anthony and marley and
we're in front of pike place market
located in our hometown of seattle
washington drew we love seattle so much
not just because of the great scenery
and great coffee but there's some places
that mean so much to us personally so
come with us and let us show you around
[Music]
we are at the iconic space needle a
signature staple for the seattle skyline
of course it's iconic but it's personal
for us because on our first trip to
seattle in 2015
this was the spot when we decided that
we were going to move to seattle and now
it just represents the love that we have
for this city well drew that's just a
snapshot of this beautiful city of
seattle we hope you love it as much as
we do we can't wait for you to come
visit see you soon
hi drew it's chef nick i'm here at
arizona's family studios in phoenix
arizona one of the things i love about
my hometown of phoenix is it has 365
days of sunshine come on let me show you
welcome to tempe beach park you have
people that are riding their bikes
people walking skateboarding paddle
boarding at night time there's concerts
it's a really happening spot
we're here at the beautiful desert
botanical garden i love this place
because i used to take my daughter here
when she was little they have the most
beautiful butterflies and they have over
50 000 types of plants we are here with
dana the director of marketing dana can
you tell us a little bit about what
makes this place so special the garden
is just such an icon in the valley we're
filled with all these beautiful desert
plants from around the world plus we
have the most beautiful exhibitions and
events throughout the year it's just a
great place to immerse yourself in
nature and explore the desert
and now we're here at chic chef
marketplace i create every single
product that is on the shelf
not only is it created by me it's
created with love it's just a beautiful
snapshot of this beautiful town of
phoenix i can't wait for you to come and
visit yourself see you soon
hey drew i'm will grimes this is my
business partner eli schmidt we are the
mile high property brothers today we're
at cbs4 we're gonna be showing you
everything we love about denver more
importantly what you might not know
about denver but it's work hard play
hard here what do you love eli guys
people in denver we love to work hard we
love to get after our business but even
more so we love to have fun we freaking
love it here so we're gonna check out
what a typical day for a coloradan might
look like
here we are at washington park in the
heart of denver this park guys is
centered around one of the biggest
focuses that locals have in denver and
that's fitness there is no lack of
things to do here
[Music]
the dairy block is often not known from
even the locals so it is a true secret
spot it is what they call an activated
alley or micro district they've actually
taken what was a normal alley just
between two big buildings and they put
restaurants and shops some interactive
artwork on the weekends you can find
farmers markets you can find bingo
karaoke all sorts of cool stuff out here
what a pleasure to show you guys
everything denver means to us guys
denver is fit it's active we're
progressive we're about our business but
we're about our food and our fun as well
so if you're thinking about coming out
this way at least paying us a visit
make sure you reach out
see you guys next time
[Music]
you